general manager of your San Francisco
49ers back here on the Rich Eisen show
John Lynch how are you John Lynch I'm
doing all right rich yeah it's it's uh
you know this time of year is always an
exciting one and and we're certainly
filled with the excitement and excited
about our prospects you know but but
there's life too rich and I think
everybody knows that you know we woke a
woke to sobering news of what happened
in our community down Steel Roy so heavy
hearts here in the midst of a lot of
excitement but our teams Kyle did a
great job of addressing our team this
morning just to keep these people in
your hearts and in your minds and you
know heavy hearts in our community with
what happened in the horrific tragedy in
Gilroy yeah well well said John I
believe it has been confirmed a
six-year-old boy lost his life at the
Garlic Festival that was being held
there at you're six years old which is
absurd and so so um coach addressed this
with the team today you see I just felt
we're gonna do a moment of silence out
here before practice and you know you
just you always want to over communicate
to your players and these players are
people as well and and they all have it
on their hearts and so I think Kyle does
a tremendous job of that and you know
just right before I got on with you Bob
Langer our public great relations
director you know showed me a picture of
the father of the six-year-old and there
he is in a Jimmy G Jersey you know and
so it's just the link and but but you
know I think what what people forget is
that that we're all people we all have
families and so everybody's heart is
heavy today throughout the nation but
particularly here in in our community
well I'm glad you said something about
that John Lynch San Francisco 49ers GM
joining me here on the show you you
mentioned Jimmy G let's go let's go to
it right here any worse than where what
are you seeing what do you what do you
what are you noticing John he's doing
outstanding his recovery has been just
exemplary huh you know I have found over
my years as a player around tremendous
athletes that you know they're really
special athletes the gifted guys tend to
heal quicker as well
and Jimmy certainly did that and and
have to give him a lot of credit with
the vigor he attacked his rehab with he
did a really nice job and so I think you
know knock on wood he's done a
tremendous job thus far there's been no
restrictions thus far in the first
couple days of training camp today we
put pads on so these are all steps that
he'll have to take but he's doing a
really nice job and I think he and our
coaching staff did a nice job he's a guy
we all know needs to play football you
know any quarterback you talk to you can
talk it you can put it on a board you
can watch film and that's all great but
you have to play it and so our challenge
last year was how do we try to simulate
him playing because he hasn't had a ton
of game action without him playing and
the answer is you can't ever do that but
we needed to do the best job possible
and so Kyle and his staff were
incredibly creative coming up with ways
to do that and Jimmy really embrace that
and so here we are and and excited to
have him back have we talked to him
about getting out of bounds John have
you done that that discussion has been
had on all levels and so how does that
go walk me through how that conversation
actually was it as simple as me just
laying it out there like you did you do
that I mean what do well I left it to
Kyle because I you know I felt like at a
certain point number number number one I
guess it is you know I guess that could
cross over into my job but I let the
coaches do the coaching and I think Kyle
said it rather emphatically and it's
part of it I think it's part of what you
love about Jimmy um and that's why his
teammates all have his back he's a
tremendous teammate but there is a point
where you just got to be smart and and I
think that point has been hammered home
and we we look forward to seeing that
happen all right now let's talk about
some other guys who missed some time
last year due to injury and that
includes your top choice in the draft
Nick Bosa how is he looking now John I
mean he looked extraordinary okay you
know throughout our offseason he did
have a little hiccup with the little
piano Sammy he's stranded in the OTAs
but he's come back and we're managing
him making sure that it's under percent
but and building him back into the
action but from day one
you know he he was doing at this level
what we anticipated that he would do
what he always did in college and that's
when he's on the field he went and
whether it's the run game the pass game
he's a very complete and polished
football player and I think the thing
that you know that's always nice when
you when you expect something from a guy
like that and then he comes out and
doesn't and he's got a lot of work to do
he knows that but I think the thing
we're really proud of him and expected
as well is that he'd be he'd be welcomed
by his teammates and and I think that's
the thing that we heard from the
teammates at Ohio State and has quickly
happened here that guys really enjoy him
and the person that he is as well and so
we're really happy about that next doing
a tremendous job why are you gonna bring
up how much you want in college to me
John well I got to do that personally
and as a team but we're at Rose Bowl
practices was actually something where I
and Nick both happened fortuitously to
show up we were down watching Ohio State
that got obviously a ton of talent and
Adam Peters our vice president player
personnel was with me and Nick happened
to be there and the first time he had
been around his team and and Adam asked
as we often do a used some of the you
know who were some of the toughest guys
you played against in your college
career and he looked like kind of
deadpan did Adam and said you know I
don't know how much film you watched me
in college but I didn't lose many rushes
it was just straight up as I said he's
right he's got a point
yeah how quickly did you put his name in
after calamari was selected yeah pretty
quickly by that point we were very
convicted they were there it was a tough
choice there was a another defensive
lineman Quinton Williams he was an
extraordinary player and and you know we
had them both as dominant football
players and really had an equal great
our team needed an edge edge presence
aside from on the other side of d4 is a
guy who we traded for a very productive
player and I think those two are gonna
add a ton and so he just fit for us and
handed it in very quickly yeah man I
mean it's amazing isn't
that that one team chooses what they
hope to be who they hope to be their
quarterback of the future
leaving the guy who you hope to put that
quarterback of the future on his behind
every single time you face him it's
amazing how the draft can work like that
John huh isn't it you know I think we
were convicted regardless of who Arizona
took unless that guy was Nick bosun and
you know there was some intrigue there
but yeah we had a feeling that it was
going to be Kyler and it's a it's a
great challenge you know you look at our
division now you got golf you got
Russell Wilson then you got Kyler it was
who's coming in here and it's gonna make
for some fun football it is the NFC West
no doubt about it John Lynch general
manager the 49ers and a button you
pushed last year I liked a lot you know
when you when you take somebody who's
been trying to get on the field and
prove that he is in every down back that
you can depend upon him on first second
and perhaps third down that you want to
give that guy the opportunity in Jerick
McKinnon I thought that him and Jimmy G
and then obviously you didn't even get a
single snap out of MacKinnon last year
how is he he's on pup right now are we
gonna see him you think seeing him here
soon
you know we kind of shut him down for a
week yet a flare up as often happens in
these ACL recoveries has had a really
nice recovery I think you know people
he's he's a head of Jimmy and in terms
of when the injury happened and people
are saying well why is Jimmy on the
field and and he is and I think the
nature of the position running back
those legs better be right it's very
reactive you've got to really put your
foot in the ground and cut and such and
so we've been extra diligent and patient
and then allowing Jarek to have that
time and then he did have a little flare
up here at the end you know we kind of
put him in a program where he just he
rested for a week then we'll wrap him
back up and I think you know in the
second you know at the end of the first
week of August we anticipate Aven Jarek
back on the field you put him in a back
field with you know Tevin Coleman Matt
Breda and we feel like we have at
options along with Kyle use check our
fullback so you know we feel real good
about that position and really excited
about having a guy we we really work
last year and unfortunately never got
the chance to get him on the field but
Jarek will be a big part of it John
Lynch 49ers GM here on the Rich Eisen
show okay
were you in favor of the change for
replay to include pass interference
offensive and defensive pass
interference is someone who obviously
played a position as you did and now
you're in the position that you are in
right now did you were you in favor you
know to be honest and this is kind of a
weak answer but I had mixed emotions
because I you know you watch something
like that which happened in New Orleans
and and of course you you don't want
that to ever happen again but I also
knew from having been around this league
sometimes when you do something like
this you open up Pandora's box and where
does it stop and what are the unintended
consequences and I think this is a big
material change and you know everybody's
sitting here now it's the way it is
thinking okay I was this gonna play out
and you know how our coach is going to
save you know that you know so that at
the right time they can go you know
throw that flag and it it's going to be
really interesting now the good thing
from experience is I think you've seen
it over the years I've seen it over the
years typically something like this you
think it's going to be a huge deal and
it doesn't typically play out to be that
fundamental of a change I'm hoping
that's the case and I'm hoping it can
help prevent a situation but I think
only time will tell and and we're all
sitting back and still trying to figure
out exactly what this means
yeah the unintended consequence what it
looks like to me John is gonna be when
you open up replay to review something
than anything that's allowed to be
reviewed gets reviewed yeah and you know
fans thought let's put this in here to
avoid another NFC Championship game from
happening that's cool but when suddenly
you know they're looking at 12 men on
the field and then the play later on
it's not 12 men on the field so the play
stands is called but we noticed looking
at the all 22 somebody pushed off and
and then suddenly you're like well where
did this pass interference play come
into two bearing like well what happened
here and and that's the unintended
consequence certainly certainly if it
happens in the fourth core
again it's gonna drive some people nut
so I'm wondering well you know what what
what will happen then that's my issue so
I and I've been privy to a lot of these
meetings and I think you know the league
I appreciate the honesty but I'm kind of
like well we better figure this out
because I've heard a lot of different
versions of what it is I've heard hey
this is only to prevent something like
what happened in New Orleans but the
standard rule and replay is exactly what
you've said once you open that
everything's under review so but I am
hoping at some version of something that
is obvious you know Kyle Shanahan I
think has a great description he
happened to you know be in Cabo when
that's when that NFC Championship was
being played and and you know he said
you know I was with uh at a restaurant
bar and and all the people in Mexico who
had no idea of the rules of football
they knew that that wasn't right like it
should be something that obvious right
and that should be overturned
but you know the ticky-tack stuff let's
leave that alone and let's just play do
you have a conversation with Kyle about
what his standard is going to be to
throw the flag or I mean is there like
we're having a lot of those
conversations and he is with his staff
and you know I think you know that's
going to be part of the strategy and you
know I I think that's that's going to be
fun to see play out and so you know and
I think again going back to experience
you never really know and I think
oftentimes we build it up this is going
to be a huge change in football and then
it really isn't and so I'm hopeful that
that's the case and that it really is
for the for those few circumstances that
are really materially changed the game
but I just I don't have the answer on
that right now but yeah well take off
the suit and put the business card away
what would John Lynch the Pro Bowl
player have thought about this as a
defensive guy I probably thought it was
garbage you know one thing I figured out
earlier I remember her mad words saying
Richburg you know because I could I
could be you know the the back judge is
a safety you were back there with them a
lot and he used to say if you just nice
to that guy back there if you call him
at like
imagine if you went back there and these
guys are getting yelled at Kenton called
all kinds of names just say hello how's
your family and you say their name I
rich how you doing
how's your family you have no idea how
long that would go and it took me about
till you're four or five and took her
meds to tell me and I used that the rest
then and they usually treated me really
well back there minutes left with John
Lynch here on the Rich Eisen show okay
speaking of family what do you think
it's gonna be like on Saturday when Pat
Bowlen gets enshrined in the Pro
Football Hall of Fame I think it's going
to be tremendous and you know I think
everybody's only wish is that Pat could
be here to experience that he was a
tremendous owner you know I got to play
in Denver for four years and Pat was
really the impetus for that happening
you know I I you know used to run up to
him skiing that wasn't supposed to be
skiing but I always did and then I used
to see him up in Beaver Creek and we
started having conversations about
perhaps someday joining the Broncos and
that that ended up with me being there
and him telling me I know I could ski
and so so buddy great yeah he's awesome
ivy you waited til I signed my contract
and today it's been great seeing you up
in the mountains all these years by the
way you're no longer allowed get off the
skis yeah but he was great because
Richie gave you every resource that you
needed to win he was always around but
he let people do their jobs and you know
he was a unique owner we do we do a
college pool Greek the Steve
Antonopoulos who's actually presenting
him the longtime trainer in Denver would
pick five or six guys every year every
Thursday we'd be in Greeks office and
the college pool and mr. Boland was part
of that and took some time for me to get
it you know because you're owner being
there talking trash to you about your
picks and then he loved if you'd fire
right back at him and he's just a
tremendous owner the winning speaks for
itself and long overdue and and he along
with my old teammate Champ Bailey who
you knew he'd be a first bout they got
that one right and really happy for
those guys along along with the entire
class what my champ so good John
he jeans he had a good great team yeah
there's guys
this level you're playing with this the
greatest athlete but there are the Barry
Sanders the Deion's and Deion Sanders
the champ Bailey's that are just a
little bit different and you know champ
was a guy who and then on top of that
mixed this incredible athleticism that
was a you know like a high four to guy
of 43 inch vertical leap with an
incredible will to be great and you know
I remember when I first really started
respecting Champ Bailey as a football
player I was in the Pro Bowl and
typically in the Pro Bowl people then
didn't like hitting particularly
cornerback stand and that's you know
guys that even would during the season
and I remember champ mixing it up there
and when I was on the same team with him
and saying man I could play with this
guy and eventually I got that
opportunity he's just he could do
anything you asked he could have played
offense and played it at a high level
had he been given the opportunity in the
NFL and just one of those superior
athletes and a tremendous competitor as
well
well you and just to wrap this up John
you knew you as somebody who worked and
TV for a while two before taking this
gig that you currently have with the
Niners probably knows Pat Bowlen was
beyond influential and the television
side of things for the NFL and without
question NFL Network would never have
existed if it wasn't for Pat Bowlen yeah
on all those committees and there are
certain people that you know Jerry Jones
and and Robert Kraft we hear about all
the time Padgett in here about as much
but you talk to people within the league
and they talk about his imprint on this
league and the success that that we're
having as a league at pet Bolin's
imprint is all over this league and and
that's that's really cool because he's a
very he was a great man as well and a
terrific owner cool is a perfect word
for him in it
yeah it is that's what he was shades
either in some sort of leather or fur at
certain times depending on the decade I
mean John you are first-rate class act
you're gonna be in that room with them
as well one day that is that's gonna
happen and I appreciate in the interim
you're just joining the show as much as
you have thanks rich I appreciate it
let's chat again soon that's at John
Lynch 49ers
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app